hi guys dr. Berg here in this video
we're going to talk about the long-term
effects of low carbohydrates in the diet
okay a lot of times when you read the
news or get advice from a dietitian
they're going to say oh you can do a
ketogenic diet for a short period of
time but don't do it long-term because
there's so many side effects okay so
let's talk about that number one there
is no essential carbohydrate your the
central amino acid that's protein
essential fatty acids that's fat but
there is no essential carbohydrates what
you do need carbohydrates you need types
of carbohydrates could not recover
hydrate fake but for the vitamins and
minerals for example you need vegetable
carbohydrates for all the vitamins and
minerals that's why you need them okay
not because the carbohydrates our bodies
will not suffer from not having or
consuming glucose okay you say well we
need that for energy you know you don't
your body is much better run on
fat fuel or ketones not glucose or
people say well a kind of a tie-in like
a low carb diet is a low calorie diet
they're kind of meaning the same but
they're not a low carb diet is not a low
calorie diet there are two separate
things okay and they'll say well low
carbs are going to starve your thyroid
of nutrients well no it's not
the thyroid doesn't need glucose it
needs nutrition doesn't need a lot of
sugar so when you go on a low-calorie
diet that can make the thyroid suffer
simply because you're depriving it of
nutrients okay there's nothing to with
carbohydrates when I recommend a
ketogenic diet I'm recommending
unlimited vegetables okay by the way so
you want to do a lot of those we're not
even factoring factoring that ends so we
need the nutrients from vegetables but
we don't need the nutrients from grains
simply because of the difficulty in
digesting grains and the gluten effect
that it can create on our body it turns
into sugar very very fast and then I was
like this it's like they say right they
say you shouldn't do a low carbohydrate
long term because no one can stick to it
and you're going to cheat
you're going to crave that's not true
first of all this is a diet that you can
stick with because your cravings go away
and your hunger goes away okay that's
the two barriers of any diet if you do a
low calorie diet or high carbohydrate
diet you're going to be craving and it's
going to be hard to stick to that or
here's another one they'll say that they
say that a low carb diet is a high
protein diet no it's not low
carbohydrates and high protein are
coming two separate things I recommend a
moderate amount of protein three to six
ounces and that's totally reasonable and
you need those amino acids for building
body proteins and then they say well
it's not healthy because you're omitting
a food group well omitting bread pasta
cereal crackers biscuits waffles
pancakes yeah you're meeting those
groups because those are not healthy all
right you can get your B vitamins from
other foods you don't have to get them
from the grains or they'll say that OA
ketogenic diet a low low carb diet is
going to lead to a disease called
diabetes or create ketoacidosis which is
another lie because ketoacidosis will
only occur if you are a type 1 diabetic
and you're in a situation where you
completely run out of insulin and you
have this serious disease ok that's
completely different then a healthy
person doing a nutritional ketosis or
healthy type of ketosis that they're not
going to get ketoacidosis and that's
like a severe high acid level of the
body you're not going to get that it's
almost actually it's probably impossible
to get it so you don't have to worry
about that again it's someone reckon
it's like because two words have are
similar they're saying they're identical
ketoacidosis and ketosis they're not
identical they're similar because they
say ketones but they're not identical
but they're similar it doesn't mean
they're the same alright so the truth is
that when you do a low carb diet you fix
insulin resistance and when you fix
insulin resistant
you allow the body to absorb nutrients
way more nutrients but not just the
minerals like potassium magnesium
chromium without a man AAA e the B
vitamins vitamin D omega-6 fatty acids
when you have insulin resistance you can
absorb those nutrients so the benefit of
long-term low carbohydrates in the diet
we're going to reduce insulin you're
going to heart improvements weight and
weight loss improvements skin
improvements like acne is going to go
away positive ovarian syndrome is going
to go away
let's liver fat less diabetes less
insulin resistance
better cognitive function better mood
less dementia I mean it's kind of
no-brainer but I do know that every time
we have a recommendation that's so
positive you have to have some someone
that objecting to it that it just just
always happens like that so you just
pretty much have to realize that of
course someone's going to object to it
just ignore that and do a low carb diet
all right thanks for watching hey if you
haven't already subscribed press this
little button down below okay thanks